[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: What if
you could inspect
a machine learning model
with minimal code required?
What if you could even see
if your model was being fair
or not?
We'll cover all that and
more on today's episode
of "AI Adventures."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to "AI
Adventures," where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode,
we're going to
look at the What-If
Tool, an open-source project
from the People and AI Research
team at Google.
It's designed to help you
probe your models to better
understand its behavior.
Now, a few episodes
ago, we looked
at Lucid, which was
great for understanding
convolutional networks.
It's only fitting
that we now look
at What-If Tool, which
specializes in structured data
and text.
Let's take a look at
what it looks like.
The What-If Tool, or WIT, can be
used inside a Jupyter or Colab
notebook or embedded into the
TensorBoard web application.
Today, we'll just
look at one example
data set, our old friend,
the US Census data set.
It's a nicely-sized data set
for this type of exploration
and it has many of the flaws
of a real-world data set,
so we can have some pretty
interesting findings.
In this example, two
models were trained
on the Census data set,
a linear classifier
and a deep classifier.
So they'll be compared to
each other as we use the tool.
Within the tool,
they are referred
to as Model 1 and Model 2.
The first view of
the What-If Tool
has Facets Dive embedded in it.
You can use it to slice and
dice your data along the x
and y-axes, as well
as see how your data
points are distributed.
Longtime viewers will
recall an early episode
of "AI Adventures"
about the Facets tool.
If you were wondering whatever
happened to that, well,
here's your answer.
The Facets tool has been
integrated into the What-If
Tool and updated
with more features.
Facets Dive is
incredibly flexible
and can create multiple
interesting visualizations
through its ability to bucket,
scatter, and color data points.
You can click on
values in the chart
and edit them to see
what the prediction would
be for your newly edited value.
Try doing this near
the decision boundary
to get a better understanding
of what features have a greater
effect on the outcome
of your predictions.
Here, we change the age and
hours per week of a data point
to see if that changes the
outcome of the prediction
and by how much.
Notice that the predictions
for both the linear model
and the deep model
are shown here.
This view also
features an ability
to show the nearest
counterfactuals.
The nearest counterfactual is
the most similar data point
that got a different
classification.
Once you turn on the
toggle, each time
you click a data point,
its counterfactual
also gets highlighted.
Here, we see an example
where these two data
points are very similar, but
the occupations are different.
Now let's move over
to the next tab.
Yeah, this tool's got two
more tabs of information.
The next one is called
Performance and Fairness,
which allows us to look at
overall model performance
and ask questions about model
performance across data slices.
Be sure to set that
Ground Truth feature
in the upper left, which
is the label that we'll
be predicting on, in order to
get the most out of this panel.
We can try moving the
prediction threshold around
for each of the models to see
how it impacts that confusion
matrix.
We can also choose to
slice by up to two fields
and then select various
fairness optimization strategies
to see how that affects the
threshold values in each model.
Now, the third tab is
not to be left out.
Here, we see Facets Overview
embedded into the What-If Tool.
You can use this to look at
the distribution of your data
points across all the
different features,
as well as some key
information about each feature.
This is a great way to spot
imbalanced data, as well.
There's a lot of features, a
lot of use cases for the What-If
Tool, so we're not going to be
able to cover them all today.
But if you're interested
in learning more about it,
let me know in the comments
below or on Twitter,
and I'll try to make
another episode to dive
into the other features of
this tool in more detail.
And if you can't wait for that
to happen, go ahead and join
the What-If Tool community
on our Google Group.
There, you'll find
announcements of new features
and all sorts of
lively discussions.
I've included a clickable
link below in the description.
Thanks for watching this episode
of Cloud "AI Adventures."
And if you enjoyed
it, click the button
and be sure to subscribe to get
all the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, check out
the What-If Tool
and learn about how
your model is operating.
[MUSIC PLAYING]